so he's right what did he say that was
wrong that's a perfect example of
feelings over facts she pulled the Greta
Thunderbird what did he say that was
incorrect she went how did he exists
when I say that was wrong yeah what did
he say you're just something you're just
it's just like you'll you're throwing
out these facts like and you think of
the jealous a woman's sole purpose is to
be a mother okay there's nothing more
there's nothing more okay whilst I do
believe there is nothing more important
than not actually I don't believe that I
don't believe that there's there's more
to women in society what's more
important than having children name five
things being healthy no no no I'm not
asking you Janella what's the name five
things
um
being healthy as a pre-worker your
actual career your dreams from a little
girl yeah with your career from from a
child all girls we all have a dream like
whatever the truth it's Charming usually
not all of us have the biggest challenge